salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je
voulais profiter d'une énième
embrasement du conflit israélo
palestinien
pour essayer de sortir du manichéisme
dompter souvent victimes ce conflit en
effet dans les médias on voit souvent
des images de civils palestiniens
confronté à l'armée israélienne l'une
des mieux équipées au monde
et de fait et bien les processus
psychologique étant ce qu'ils sont on a
tendance
instinctivement à se ranger du côté de
celui qu'on estime être le plus faible
c'est ce que résumait le roi arthur à
yves 1 en disant qu'on peut douter de
tout sauf de la nécessité de se trouver
du côté des opprimés
ça peut paraître logique comme ça mais
dans les histoires de conflits
politiques territoriaux et cetera c'est
souvent extrêmement simpliste et les
réalités sont souvent plus compliqué que
les gentils d'un côté et les méchants de
l'autre ceux qui peuvent paraître des
victimes à l'instant t peut aussi être
coupable à l'instant t - 1
aussi aujourd'hui je voulais revenir sur
certains arguments utilisés par les pro
palestiniens pour tenter de vous montrer
que ce conflit peut être vu d'autres
façons et donc de façon beaucoup moins
binaire qu'elle ne l'est
souvent dans les médias le premier point
sur lequel je voulais revenir et l
accusation qui est fait contre israël
d'être un état génocidaire un génocide
c'est l'élimination systématique d'une
population en raison de son appartenance
ethnique ou religieuse par exemple voici
la courbe représentant la population
juive à travers les âges
comme on peut le voir dans la période
1930 1950 il y a une importante
diminution du nombre de juifs vivent
dans le monde
on passe grosso modo de 17 millions à
11,12 millions évidemment c'est la
marque de la shoah et maintenant voici
une courbe présentant l'évolution des
populations juives et arabes en israël
palestine sur les dernières décennies
comme vous pouvez le voir les deux
courbes croise il n'y a pas de trace de
diminution d'une population ou d'une
autre et même la population arabe croît
plus vite que la population juive
puisque les deux courbes se croisent et
donc mais tristement il n'y a pas de
trace de génocide si israël réellement
à génocidaire et bien dans ce cas là
israël est vraiment très très très très
nul en génocide
le deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
revenir et l'accusation qui fait à
l'encontre d'israël d'un état raciste et
ayant mis en place un apartheid un état
raciste qui discrimine une partie de la
population
normalement vote des lois réduisant les
droits politiques et sociaux voir les
accès à certaines parties du territoire
à une fraction de la population
il y a un droit différentiel en israël
il faut savoir qu'il n'ya pas que des
juifs il ya aussi des arabes qu'on
appelle les arabes israéliens et qui
sont en fait les descendants des
palestiniens qui sont restés sur leur
terre lors de la fondation d'israël
israël leur a ordonné la nationalité et
la citoyenneté avec le droit de vote
aujourd'hui ces arabes israéliens ont
les mêmes droits que les israéliens de
confession juive
il n'y a pas de droits discriminatoire
envers l'un ou l'autre
également il faut savoir que lors de la
création de l'état d'israël
une partie de la population
palestinienne est parti se réfugier dans
les pays alentour souvent arabe le liban
la syrie la jordanie et l'egypte et une
partie de ces pays les ont incorporé
c'est le cas en fait uniquement de la
jordanie qui a vraiment intégrer les
palestiniens sa population l'egypte elle
les a très vite renvoyé notamment dans
la bande de gaza et le liban et la syrie
par contre les ont gardés sur leur
territoire et ont créé des camps de
réfugiés pérenne donc pas forcément
détente et remise des camps en dur et
aujourd'hui encore vous avez ces camps
de réfugiés vous avez des gens qui sont
considérés comme des réfugiés
palestiniens
alors que depuis trois à quatre
générations ils naissent sur un autre
sol que le sol de palestine et de fait
ces populations étant considérés comme
réfugiés elles ne sont pas politiquement
intégré à leur pays d'accueil et parfois
même pas économiquement ils ont des
statuts discriminatoire c'est un petit
peu comme si chez nous en france lors de
la fin de la
la guerre d'espagne on avait accueilli
les populations républicains espagnols
en les parquant dans des camps et en les
gardant dans des camps pendant des
décennies parce que en france lors de on
a effectivement accueilli entre 300000
quand même et quatre cent mille réfugiés
républicains qui fuyaient le nouveau
régime franquiste et ses populations ont
été très vite intégré à notre population
française et leurs descendants
aujourd'hui sont considérés comme ayant
un ou plusieurs grands parents espagnols
mais sont des citoyens comme les autres
il n'y a pas de droits spécifiques aux
descendants d'espagnols et ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec les réfugiés
palestiniens
et bien c'est comme si en france nous on
n'avait pas intégré ces réfugiés
espagnols comme si aujourd'hui encore à
la frontière pyrénéenne
on avait encore des camps de réfugiés
espagnols 2 3 ou 4e génération à vous de
voir donc qui est raciste
entre israël et les pays arabes
alentours d'ailleurs cette question de
l'intégration au pays d'accueil des
réfugiés palestiniens est extrêmement
important puisque si ces pays avaient
fait leur devoir de solidarité vis-à-vis
des palestiniens et il ya peut-être que
cette question israélo palestinienne
aujourd'hui serait un petit peu moins
inextricable et qu'on n'aurait pas cette
question du retour à traiter enfin
j'aimerais revenir sur une troisième
accusation qui est faite à israël qui
est l'accusation d'être un état
terroriste israël effectivement parfois
bombarde certaines zones d'habitation
notamment à gaza en ce moment parce que
le hamas utilise les populations civils
comme boucliers humains
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que deux
salles avant ces bombardements prévient
les populations pour leur laisser le
temps d'évacuer
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que dans la
presse on peut avoir de belles images
d'immeubles qui sont frappés par des
missiles tout simplement parce que les
journalistes sont prévenus avant et on
le temps est tranquillement installé
leurs caméras de son côté par contre le
hamas lui envoie des requêtes qu'ils
tirent depuis une zone peuplée vers
israël dans le but de faire des morts
parmi les civils
il est écrit dans la charte du hamas que
l'un des buts est l'éradication d'israël
également la question
israélo-palestinienne génère du
terrorisme à l'international en 1981 en
france on a eu l'attentât 10 de la rue
des rosiers dans laquelle
une bombe a explosé près d'une synagogue
et faisant quatre morts et plusieurs
dizaines de blessés
on sait aujourd'hui que cet attentat a
été organisée par un commando
palestinien
également en 2012 mohamed merah à tuer
des enfants juifs dans une école juive à
toulouse
au nom des enfants palestiniens en
janvier 2015 lors des attentats
amedi coulibaly a fait un carnage dans
un hyper cacher au nom de la cause
palestinienne
encore plus près de nous la faire saluer
le pâtis peut être révoqué si samuel
patty a été assassiné par un islamiste
d'origine tchétchène se sont en partie
des pro palestiniens qu'ils ont mis une
cible dans le dos sur les médias sociaux
il ya eu toute une campagne le traitant
d'islamophobe qui a été notamment mis en
avant par un groupe pro palestiniens
appelés collectif cheikh yacine
cheikh yassine étant l'un des fondateurs
du hamas également puisqu'on ne parle
des attentes en france il faut aussi
remarquer que ceux qui manifestent pour
la palestine dans nos rues parfois en
criant allahou akbar sont aussi
tristement absents lorsqu'il y à un
deuil national
chez nous en raison d' attentat
islamiste
comme par hasard ceux qui manifestent
pour la palestine ne sont pas là pour
manifester leur solidarité avec le pays
qui les accueille quand il est victime
de terrorisme islamiste
bref le conflit israélo palestinien est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que l'on
veut bien croire chez nous avec des
gentils palestiniens d'un côté les
méchants israéliens de l'autre
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura donné
quelques éléments pour briser cette
logique manichéenne
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner à la chaîne
et sur ce je vous dis à la prochaine